you know and i think you know uh our
previous speaker dr lonnie brooks who
was talking
about after futures as well as afro
queer features i think one of the things
that he pointed out that was really
eye-opening for me
was this this notion that um that
uh that black people have have had to be
futurists because their marginalized
present was so
so difficult that in a way they had to
project a better future for themselves
in order to
to kind of have a present that they
could live with and um i'm wondering is
do you feel as though that's a similar
thing for queer populations
i do i actually i i have a i believe
this is a
saying of mine but that queer people
actually equip people make some of the
best futurists because for most of our
lives
we've had to hope that tomorrow that
tomorrow will be better for us than
today
um that we will be more respected more
welcome more accepted
um in the world of tomorrow the world of
next week in the world of next year
and then we happened today and we know
yes we're
our i'm losing my trajectory here but
yes we're making progress um but it is
it is scatter shot progress we are
you know often going two steps forward
one step back um we're not there yet